all right next we have this from the
national review here's a really
interesting report it says planned
parenthood dresses itself up in pink and
calls itself an essential women's
healthcare organization but its business
model tells a different story each year
planned parenthood clinics perform
upwards of 330 000 abortions making the
group the most prolific abortion
provider in the country but recently
planned parenthood has quietly begun
expanding into a new arena hormone
therapy for individuals with gender
dysphoria
a service the group calls gender
affirming care
hormone therapy has become popular as a
means of artificially suppressing the
sex characteristics of those who feel
misaligned with their biological sex
and now it says uh pleb's most recent
report from 2019 recorded more than 200
centers in 31 states that provide
hormone therapy for transgender patients
according to the group's website that
number is even larger now
close to 300 centers across 38 states
maybe this will be enough for for anyone
especially on the right who still
doesn't understand why this is an
important issue
well why is planned parenthood getting
involved in it
why do you think planned parenthood has
decided
that now they want to start handing out
hormone
therapy
that's
got nothing to do with so-called
reproductive rights
what you're doing in many cases is
you're making it impossible for people
to
reproduce so this is the
organization that bills itself as the
leading provider of
reproductive health care
and now they're giving out pills that
are
make people impotent infertile
unable to reproduce
which actually the more that you think
about it it kind of makes sense because
that's what they do with abortion
that that's always been the morbid irony
of planned parenthood is that they say
that they're interested in
reproductive health but it's actually
reproductive destruction is what they're
trying to do they're trying to destroy
the capacity to reproduce
and they're trying to destroy what has
been reproduced already
because as we know i mean uh
abortion itself has nothing to do with
if the word reproductive rights or
reproductive justice means anything at
all
abortion can't be related to it because
once abortion happens as i have always
said
the reproduction has already occurred
you are killing something that's already
been reproduced
so in another sense it actually makes a
lot it actually makes a lot of sense
that they would get involved in this
because their
mo their mission
is to prevent reproduction this is
another means by which to do that
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content